hello world in today's video we are
continuing with s free and we are going
to perform some basic operations on a
file like getting the file from the s
free bucket and saving the file back to
this free bucket this video we are
continuing with s 3 but this time we are
going to perform basic operations on
this free bucket from the lambda so we
are going to create a bucket from the
server list channel then we are going to
give permissions to our lambda to
perform operations in that bucket then
we are going to create a new file if
there is known or and get it we are
going to perform some operations on the
file and then we are going to save it
back and by the end you will get back a
sign or L and this is the public or L
sign with I am permissions so you can
share private files in the open Internet
securely so I will show you how to do
everything step-by-step and we will be
using the AWS SDK for node as we are
we're using for dynamo for other things
as well so let's go to the code so let's
get start as always by creating a new
directory where we are going to put our
project I will call it several s as free
operations you can put any name you want
and I will get into that directory I
will create a node project and p.m. in
it - yes and we then will create a
server less project using the template
from AWS and node after everything is
done when we get into our project that
we just created with the free files with
package.json 100 Jas and several s you
know as always the first thing we need
to do is to go to the several SML and
change the name of the solace project
now I will set the region to Ireland you
can put any reason you like but I like
airline is closed and then I will pick
my profile we got her many and I will
just put default remove some of the
comments
the next thing I want to do is I want to
modify them default lambda and change
the name to a pen text and then add an
HTTP event there will be a put to a path
called a paint pen text so whenever we
call this endpoint and we passed some
text then these text will get appended
to file and we can get the file or a
public URL back so now I will create a
bucket and to create a bucket you just
need to use the cloud formation template
to put something like these in the
server Lezama in the resources property
you just put as free operations bucket
that's the name of the resource in the
in the llamó and then you put the bucket
name and I will put several SS free
operations bucket you can put any name
you want if you pick this name this will
be taken by me because name of the
buckets are global in all AWS this will
create a private bucket for your account
with all the default properties if you
want to have more detail in your
properties you can add whatever you want
in this template and it will create a
bucket for you the next thing we want to
do is we want to give permissions so
lambda to write in this bucket and to
get the items in this bucket and to do
that I will just add permissions in the
I am roll off the server less yeah Mel I
will add these free actions that this
lambda can perform to list the bucket to
get the object to put the object and
into the resource packet that we just
created if I was doing this in
production I will have this name as an
environmental variable but I think for
now I don't want to add that complexity
to this code but if you are interested
on learning a little bit more about
environmental variables just let me know
in the comments and I can make a whole
video out of them now we are going to
our handle Cheers our several HTML is
ready and I'm going to change the name
of the lambda to from hello to append
text and there
we are going to create a new file that
is the one that will be performing all
the operations in the industry
I just put manage file you can put any
name something better I sure they're
better words for this it's just very bad
at naming stuff takes me hours so I just
pick any name and I will put this manage
file and I will create it and in there
we will put all the operations that we
want to do into our s free to get
started we need to require in our file
AWS and s free module and then I will
create two two constants that will be
the bucket name and the object the file
name this see Sara will be using if I
will be doing it production I will be
using environmental variables for now I
just have it here and then we will have
one main method that it will be called
append text and in that method we can we
want to do these things first we want to
get the file and then we want to append
some text to it file so it will be a
basic txt file plain text when the pen
time textured file in the new line for
example and I want to say the file again
into the the bucket and then we want to
get oral the public URL for this this
file so we will do this a chain of
promises so we will have four promises
chained together that will be performing
different things the first thing we want
to do is to get an object to do that we
will be using this function called get
s3 object and the only thing that this
is doing is calling the AWS SDK get
object with the bucket there is a
constant and Hakeem and I just put the
response condom type it's a plain text
but that's not really needed and I'm
making a promise of this so this is
returning a promise the next thing we
want to do is we want to you want to
append some text to that to that file
so this get as free object will be
returning buffer
and this buffer we can then pass to this
function append text and we will first
have no no information in there so that
this buffer will be undefined it will be
not found and then we just return the
text that we want to append and then if
there is something in the buffer we just
convert it to string and if it's encoded
with ASCII this will be we just append
in a new line but text so this is the
way to confer to transform a buffer to a
string this will just do what we need to
do if you want to do more complex
operations for example if you are
working with images you can do exactly
the same get object and maybe the
different content type and then here you
can do it like resizing an image or
whatever or if you are doing something
more complex with text or it will be a
shayzon this is the function that can be
creative as this is a demo I'm just
doing something super simple the next
thing we want to do is we want to save
that file into the bucket again so that
will save using the s3 put object
function will say the body into the
bucket with the content I'm plain text
the key will be the exactly same and the
body is the one that we got from the
append text and the last thing we want
to do is to get the sign Aurel this is
the public URL for that file sign with
your with proper keys so this will
expire in time so you get earn well that
you can share with other people now you
go back to our s3 object so so in the
beginning we'll have an empty fold an
empty bucket and there will be no file
so basically if we try to get this this
file we will see that there will be an
error so what if there is the file is
not there so then we need to handle this
error will be only happening once but as
we are creating everything from from the
code we need to handle that case so here
if there is an error like the file not
found for example we
just can't create the fire layer with
nothing on it so then when the next step
comes we can append text to it and
everything is nice so now we construct
the chain of promises that we need this
is exactly the same where I was in the
comment first we get the object then we
append the text then we save the object
back and then we get the sign over and
that's what we will be returning to the
handler Jia's one thing you might be
interested in knowing what is inside the
AWS SDK in that's free so just go to the
documentation and take a look at it it's
very complete you can find everything on
it and just showing you a bit here but
you'll find all these operations and
there's a lot of different things you
can do so I encourage you to take a look
at it and learn how it works because
it's very very convenient and leave you
the link in the description box so you
can find it also the code will be in the
description box as always so you can go
and check it from github so now we have
our manage file done if and save and we
go back to our handler tears then I can
call that before returning the response
so we only send a response when there
append text is completed and we can
remove a little bit what is in the body
to just return the result that is the
sign Errol and now we format it a bit we
have the missing brackets the last thing
is to grab the text that we want to
append that I will put it in the query
parameters you can put it anywhere else
but I like it from there so I will just
deploy and we can try it on the postman
and see how it works I will speed this
up for you because the deployment takes
a little while and I don't want you to
wait so now this is deployed we just
grab the URL that we get from the
endpoint and we put copy paste it in
postman and we can add the text at the
end of a query string parameters I will
put Ola and then I get oral bug I just
click there and I can request that file
and we can say hola
and then if I go on food marzia get the
same moral back and then I can see what
is inside although Mars here and I gave
food full bar and if you can put as many
things as you and it will just return
always them they were up so that's very
simple if you go to your AWS account you
will see also the bucket is created the
file is created you can check it out
from there as well this was the video
for today I hope you enjoyed it if you
did give a big thumbs up